all right I've got what is some insane
video from Donald Trump's press
conference yesterday where Donald Trump
hammered CNN for being fake news and
wouldn't take a question from Jim Acosta
and then proceeded minutes later to take
a question from Breitbart what was the
question from Breitbart was it
hard-hitting or was it a softball I'll
let you think about that for a minute or
two while I lined this up for you so
Donald Trump during this press
conference during which he admitted that
indeed he was briefed about the alleged
existence of this 35-page blackmail file
from Russia the contents of which he
questions he admitted to having been
briefed on it he took aim at fake news
he called the reporting of the story
fake news and then we had some very very
interesting exchanges related to calling
BuzzFeed a failing piece of garbage and
then not allowing CNN reporter Jim
Acosta to ask a question because quote
your fake news let's start with the
first one take a look at this I think
it's a disgrace and I say that and I say
that and that's something that Nazi
Germany would have done and did do I
think it's a disgrace that information
that was false and fake and never
happened
got released to the public as far as
BuzzFeed which is a failing pile of
garbage writing it I think they're gonna
suffer the consequences they already are
and as far as CNN going out of their way
to build it up okay as I told you
earlier in today's show I believe
BuzzFeed was right to publish the 35
page dossier I won't rehash that
conversation now check it out it's odd
that twice once on Twitter and once
during this press conference Donald
Trump associated Nazi Germany with fake
news fake news isn't the first thing I
think of Pat when I think about Nazi
Germany it's the killing of six million
Jews but maybe I'm an outlier in that
sense yeah maybe it's the second or
third that they did release propaganda
but this is clearly not fake news they
had plenty of caveats in their reporting
then now let's get to the Jim Acosta
part
Donald Trump going to war with CNN
saying your fake news and then just not
letting Jim Acosta ask a question mr.
president can you give us can you give
us a question what a Donald Trump do
right after calling CNN fake news and
denying them a question he went to a
bright part reporter of course Breitbart
associated with the alt-right regularly
promotes misleading and flat-out
inaccurate stories
what hard-hitting question did we get
from Breitbart to trump fat quotes mr.
Trump with all the problems that we've
been seeing throughout the media over
the course of the election I mean I can
barely even get through it what reforms
do you recommend for this industry here
Wow really a hard-hitting question from
not fake news Breitbart huh yeah that's
quite the softball and you gotta love
how Donald Trump is accosting Jim Acosta
by saying you're being rude Trump's
entire presence on the political stage
is projection in every way crooked
Hillary actually crooked Trump he is
saying that Jim Acosta is being rude
well I think we have no shortage of
Trump rudeness throughout this entire
campaign CNN put out a statement after
this incident saying that the reporting
that CNN did had nothing at all to do
with the reporting that BuzzFeed did and
that lumping them in together makes
absolutely no sense it is undeniably
true that CNN focused on the fact that
Donald Trump was briefed about the
blackmail file which Trump admitted to
during the press conference it the CNN
did not report on the urine fetish
details that were in the dossier a ton
of people are loving this stuff saying
take him out mr. Trump another comment
on YouTube was CNN needs to be off the
air good
job Trump go get him the report that CNN
did has been confirmed by Donald Trump
and by James clapper that yes indeed
Trump was briefed about the existence of
that blackmail file
yeah and reportedly they even threatened
to take Jim Acosta out of the room
there are plenty criticisms you can have
over CNN that are too corporatists that
they projects false balance but they're
one of the biggest news organizations in
the world and they have every right to
be in that room and ask a question is
anyone open to the idea that this type
of thing Trump yelling fake news at a
reporter is anecdotally funny and
interesting but that it actually should
make us really concerned about the Trump
administration's relationship with media
I mean we're talking about libel
lawsuits we're talking about if you
publish good stuff about Trump you're
smart if you publish bad stuff about
Trump you deserve to be sued and Trump
won't take your questions the real
problem with this story and I'll get to
the broader issues momentarily is that
people aren't understanding what was
being reported in many cases and and
conflating what BuzzFeed reported and
what CNN reported but the major issue
here is that the entire fake news thing
is ramping up to the point where it's
now a meaningless term it's been
subverted and perverted sort of like the
regressive left remember when the term
regressive left it's sort of pointed to
supposed progressives standing up for
alyttle principles or ideas the right
totally perverted that and now they just
that will now it's sort of fallen off
the radar altogether but for a while the
right would just say you're a regressive
leftist if you're just progressive and
the right doesn't agree with you in the
same way fake news at one point a very
short period of time referred to parody
news sites deliberately misleading news
and conspiracy websites everything from
you know info Wars and Alex Jones on the
right to things like natural news on the
left now fake news just means news we
don't like because we disagree with it
yeah it's just a way to dismiss things
that you don't agree with and don't want
to delve into right by calling something
fake news it means that you don't even
have to address it the other thing I
want to mention from said I could stand
in the middle of Fifth Avenue and shoot
people and I wouldn't lose voters Trump
was able to add a press conference stand
in the middle of the room
do the equivalent thing to CNN and
reporter Jim Acosta I have not heard any
major news say what Donald Trump did is
wrong and stand-up for CNN and Jim
Acosta as Pat said we can criticize CNN
and we often do but it does seem as
though Donald Trump is going to be
allowed to do whatever the hell he wants
with no repercussions that's why we have
to activate against him and that's why
we're raising money at david pakman.com
slash donate let's take a break next I
will talk to dr. Hugh Sealy stay with us
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDPS the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s